qui a dit que télé réalité politique ne
pouvait pas faire bon ménage fama
galibert dany marlène schiappa en tout
cas qu'ils avaient rendez vous hier
après midi au ministère de l'intérieur
pour parler de la lutte des violences
faites aux femmes
un débat très important organisé entre
la ministre de la citoyenneté et la
papesse de la télé réalité qui s'est
accompagné par cinq candidates parmi
elles victoria maïsano isabeau l'ena né
vers l'iss dès leur arrivée au ministère
on a senti que les filles n'étaient pas
très rodé sur les formalités et
l'attitude à adopter et maintenant alors
par contre on respecte le président de
la république voilà merci manuel et
maniema bref vous l'avez compris sur les
réseaux sociaux plus de vidéos qui
ressemble à un goûter entre copines que
du débat à proprement parler rigole chez
balenciaga pas son peu d
de quoi faire bondir certains
internautes alors des candidats de
télé-réalité ont-ils vraiment leur place
dans un ministère
mais l'audience a déjà qu'on attend d
eux qu est-ce que vous avez été foot là
bas
si vous allaitez fou que là-bas mais
avancer et évoluer faire des choses
avancent et où vont se servir des
réseaux sociaux à bon escient ah ouais
c'est une phrase qu'on vous a donné et a
pris tout seul
non mais qui souza était foot là bas
vous êtes dit quoi long mais on a parlé
on a parlé de tout la cause que l'on
pouvait mettre en lumière sur nos
réseaux sociaux et savoir comment on
pouvait utiliser nos réseaux sociaux
pour une fois pour des bals je vais
avancer vous avancez ouais vraiment on a
appris plein de choses oui bien sûr et
on a posté on a posté victoria toutes
les influences choses qui étaient avec
moi ont posté le lien bas de qu'un de
ses quoi vos idées alors c'est quoi vos
propositions pour la france mes
propositions des lacets créé un
ministère ou des réseaux ceux des
réseaux sociaux non c'est vrai c'est pas
bête mais il y en a pas c'est juste pas
et les restos disons non comment le
numérique est en fait s'ils doivent
numérique pas vraiment ouais mais ils
sont pas vraiment là-dessus quoi il y
avait des gros problème aujourd'hui
soyons répondrais que non mais c'est le
canal numéro 1 communication dans le
monde entier et aujourd'hui c'est pas
réglementé il ya rien il se passe rien
rien n'est réglementée on en parle
souvent ici le harcèlement on pourrait
tellement s'en servir correctement et
faire de belles choses que à mon avis il
faut créer ce ministère bon après ça
c'est pas moi qui le dit alors alors il
ya des petits aimants sur la souris pas
qu un petit caux tél d'abord un petit
tour de table pour que chacun se
présente ils ont chacun eu un petit sac
avec plein d'éléments comme voilà ne
s'attendait pas à être reçu comme une
personnalité politique auquel ne
comprends pas les critiques elle est
restée naturelle a justement voulu
casser les codes ce que vous dites oui
nous on est on est pas là pour être dans
des cas je pense qu'on nous attendait
pas justement pour être des femmes parce
que vous comprenez qu'il ait des
citoyens comme au niveau livre comme
d'autres autour de la table pour cartes
d'ailleurs est ce que vous comprenez ou
quoi qu'ils disent est ce qu'ils n'ont
pas autre chose à [ __ ] au niveau lycée
poids total puisque j'ai vu sur les
réseaux il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disaient qu'ils ont pensé un peu qui
sont hissés c'est n'importe quoi
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui t'énerve toi on
voit le niveau du gouvernement il est
vraiment triste je crois qu'on est tombé
au plus bas tu plus loin on a le grand
retour du club dorothée maintenant dans
un ministère peut-être que bientôt ils
vont tourner les princes de l'amour à
l'elysée je sais pas si
les gens des associations autour de la
protection de la femme qui y bossent
jour et nuit le samedi le dimanche tout
le temps c'est quelque chose non non
franchement je pense pas du tout
d'ailleurs on voit quand on voit la
vidéo on a la pression plutôt un bal
populaire non moi je suis désolé si ça
c'est représentatif du gouvernement on
n'a pas l'impression d'ailleurs que le
sujet les prêts au sérieux quand on
arrive à regarder ça moi franchement ça
me fait mal au ventre ça me fait déjà
mal au ventre quand ma fille est allé
chez sa maman qui regardent la télé
réalité où on apprend à nos jeunes qu'il
faut faire grossir les seins s'envoyer
du botox effet avoir ses fesses au
quotidien m'ont franchement ça me
démonte de voir ça il ya des gens
beaucoup plus à eux qui devraient vous
faire kiffer je vous ai fait une petite
compil
vous avez peut-être qu'ils aient toutes
les vidéos ont été partagés sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est mon cadeau suis
partir avec regarde
bon les filles je vous emmène ou là on
va se la donnent un ministre
non marlène schiappa voilà ministre de
la citoyenneté ne le savais pas charlene
y apporte
une ans alors où par contre on respecte
le président de la république voilà
merci manuel et manuellement oui on
rigole chez lui par les deux chiens pas
on veut dès l'hôtel
[Rires]
olive olive
je continue d'avoir mal mais ça c'est un
vent en plus franchement ça me fait mal
au ventre de vous voir sourire là
sincèrement ça les
détend c'est pourtant ça parlait déjà
important mais vous étiez voilà une
image de merde là on à vous renvoyer une
image de meilleure valeur victorieuse au
mérite nous parce que vous avez avancé
sur des sujets oui alors bien sûr il
était bien sûr c'est juste qu'on n'a pas
tous filmés en fait on n'a pas passé la
soirée sont notre téléphone c'était un
cocktail on a dit beaucoup de choses à
plat fait j'ai les faits justement
laissez moi parler en fait j'ai fait une
vidéo youtube où j'ai absolument pas
sauf si vous perdez messieurs vous êtes
très su en fait vous prenez à vis de
magna pas similaires ailleurs et c'est
méprisant je parlais déjà abaissé les
femmes et vous rabaisser les chaînes sa
méprise et on n'est pas des chiens ou
donner des femmes d'accord et on agit on
essaye de faire des choses des choses
pour votre cause nous il ya des côtes ou
qu'on veut qu'on veut aider aujourd'hui
vous plaignez et quand on fait quelque
chose vous vous plaignez
vous
les maisons et
blessé devra couper tout les pc blessant
de voir des gens comme ça vous embête
écriture sa baisse ça plaît c'est
pourquoi parce que quand on fait rien
vous critiquez
vous critiquez joué j'ai fait quelque
chose nous on était là-bas on a parlé d'
or seulement on a l'impression qu'on a
parlé de désordre des violences faites
aux hommes et aux femmes d'accord on a
parlé de des du délai du harcèlement sur
les homosexuels on a parlé de plein de
choses quand on est sorti de cette
réunion on a poster des liens pour aider
des gens est la plus d'un million
follower outillage ne serait ce qu'une
seule personne qu'elle a pu sauver hier
grâce à ses réseaux sociaux et bien je
suis fier d'être ridicule
géraldine maillet moi je peux dire que
je suis d'accord avec hollywood iv c'est
rare donc du coup c'est vrai que les
deux là c'est un joueur n'est jamais
arrivé mais vont finir ensemble ces
dollars je vois ces images et c'est vrai
que ça me fait ça me fait aussi un peu
mal au vent je trouve que voilà c'est un
peu misérable c'est un peu pathétique ça
désacralise complètement la fonction et
en plus moi je vais vous dire je pense
que c'est encore plus cynique de votre
part d'ailleurs je pense que vous
racheter une virginité derco la
téléréalité par aimons tellement mis
dans une mauvaise passe de raquette de
l'harcèlement de dans tous les
programmes dont on et dont on a parlé
ici d'ailleurs avec des choses
absolument terrible que là du coup on
dit ah bon bah on va se donner une
virginité on va aller voir madame chapal
c'est très bien mais on fait vachement
de choses comme ça on va tout oublié on
va être amnésique mais en fait je pense
que c'est pas du mépris gillet shon et
vous méprisez la télé réalité si jamais
m mais un constat sévère l'argument
qu'on le fasse bien qu'on fasse ma télé
re la maîtrise et bien 4,22 cresson
d'abstention aux dernières régionales
devenir des jeunes c'est énorme ça veut
dire que la france aujourd'hui et vous
ne savez pas parler aux jeunes si
aujourd'hui il ya une mousse et des
envies c'est cela aujourd'hui c'est un
mobilier qui regarda pourraient voter
gérad tiné coup tu mens s'il y avait des
ministres aujourd'hui d'accord qui a
reçu la jeunesse pour une fois que ça
bouge quand j'ai été reçu par gabriela
talent mais ça fait autant de scandales
peut-être est-ce que c'est une femme et
que ça choque tout le monde je ne sais
pas
c'est parce que c'est les vidéos qui ont
été sensibles dans mes veines magali
magali siouplé magali aux prédictions
pression ces messieurs joseph cbge paix
mais une école de pour nous aider quand
vous les jeunes très vous sembler
grisons et ses légumes les plus d'un
million personnes qui la suivent s'il y
en a autant c'est qu'elle a aujourd'hui
une puissance servez vous de cette
puissance pour communiquer avec les
chaînes pour une fois que des gens
matthieu delormeau la galine battu
mathieu gaye le match le problème la
galice et que je sais que tu nos fils
intelligente et toi aussi certainement
et le problème c'est que vous faites
tout l' inverse c'est à dire que là ce
que vous nous montrez là pardon à ces
trois dinde à la haye d'une bagnole on
va voir la reine chapalain pas d'hier
soir la reine machin anouk et la fin de
la pièce qu'on est bien chez marc
chagall et peut-être que l'intention est
bonne ou non quand on regarde ça magali
on peut pas se dire que tu auras des
ministres et toi quand tu dit la
dernière fois que c'est bien la
chirurgie sur les gens de 16 ans que
j'étais raconte a dit quelque chose non
alors s'il te plaît mathieu sera
toujours le seul genre j'avais une
connerie oui c'était des conneries tu en
as dit donc web 2 0 j'essaye de voir nos
efforts magali l'intention est bonne
j'ai effectué sur l'épaule ou ex menez
ou pas on continuera à le faire et merci
à madame la ministre d'avoir donné la
parole à des influences us parce que
c'est une voie que magali jem a gagné
c'est excellent art que les gens qui ne
savent pas ce que c'est qu'elle
influenceurs montre leur que justement
ce sont des gens célèbres et qui parle
pour nancy scola on t'envoie samedi
citoyens qu est-ce qu on tue des
conneries
et moi je sais qu'il est formidable
magali et ça m'ennuie de voir qu'on voit
ça alors qu'elle n'est pas si on n'est
pas des ministres sur le récif au niveau
de sa gaffe il ya plein de gens qui
réalisent qu'ils disent olive olive il
était dur mais on est d'accord avec lui
mais vous avez été ressorti des citoyens
engagés parlant français les
influenceurs c'est pas vrai alors dans
les camps c'est ce que j'avais dit que
c'est ce que j'allais annoncer je pense
que la ministre alors a pu recevoir il
ya d'autres associations qui font un
énorme boulot autour de autour de tout
ça qui est un sujet qui est très très
important et ça aurait été intéressante
que ces personnes là puissent aller
là-bas d'ailleurs il ya le côté qui
s'appelle les mamans louve qui
représente le méchoui avaient déjà été
reçus vous comment était déjà reçu 1
mais jamais jamais
la mairie est reçue de pour parler de
sujets intelligent ça pourrait être
intéressant à certains moments mais
surtout d'autres collectifs delphine
que ce soit emmanuel macron avec mc fly
et carlito ou alors les influences euse
chez marlène schiappa je pense que c'est
surtout un très très beau coup de pub
pour les politiques à chaque fois j'ai
clairement c'est sûr que marlène
schiappa ses followers ont augmenté
voilà après je pense qu'il ya il ya deux
cas il ya deux métiers il ya le
politique et il yal influence de
télé-réalité d'ailleurs je pense pas
qu'il ya des connexions vraiment
possible même si les filles sont de
bonnes de bonnes pensées pour ça
concrètement ce qu'on a vu je suis pas
sûr que ça aide et aussi deux styles
d'influenceurs et les influenceurs
téléréalité et aussi d'autres influences
extérieures alors je rebondis mais il ya
influenceurs et personne de tellier mais
je suis désolé langues parlent d'une
cause c'est la cause des femmes c'est la
violence faite contre les femmes et je
suis une femme en fait et regarder ou de
rollers je pense donc que je sois un
française ou pas en fait je suis une
femme et si j'ai pu en est d au moins
une sur les 1 million de personnes qui
me suivent sur instagram et j'en ai
trois cent mille autres sur youtube et
j'ai fait une colombe vidéo où j'ai
vraiment tout expliquer ce qu'on est en
train de faire donc certes on a un petit
peu rigoler alors certes marlène
schiappa répond en direct elle m'écrit
marine dans les associations ça fait
cinq ans que je les reçois jour et nuit
et ce monsieur ne m'a jamais demandé de
rendez vous contrairement à lui aucune
influence us de m'insulter pour obtenir
un rendez vous s'ils demandent un rendez
vous il sera reçu comme tout le monde
s'en soucie canadien vous rencontrer je
remercie ses influences euse grâce à
elle beaucoup de femmes connaîtront les
dispositifs dead face aux violences
passées dans quel est ce que j'ai
souvent je me permets du coup est plus
que temps de réponse en direct il ya des
mamans louve qui représente 15 mille
maman autant la protection des angles
fallait refaire il recevra mais marée
noire soit le message est passé voilà
donc c'est une bonne nouvelle vous savez
nos réseaux sociaux on les met
gratuitement à disposition justement
pour ces associations et si on a fait
ces rendez vous moi j'ai vu par exemple
elisabeth moreno vous m'avez permis de
rencontrer sur ce plateau qui avait
promis une réunion de travail avec les
productions et bien on l'a fait cinq
jours après ça bouge on avance bien tout
ce que je te dis c'est un des très
belles vidéos qui sont ceux-là c'est pas
représentatif et à la valeur d'une alors
vous
je me dis qu'il va recevoir donc cette
association les maghrébins et les
coordonnées je devrais elle va les
recevoir car très bien merci comme à la
voyait comme ça ça va du temps vous avez
bien fait de venir au liban oui mais
voilà d'autres rendez vous
non mais dites nous ce qu'on voit ben
haim qu'équipe mais non mais parce que
franchement on leur tape tout le temps
dessus quand elles font rien c'est sa
horde il vous fait rien et la cause des
femmes dans les émissions de télé
réalité elle est vraiment les femmes
sont mises sous le sous le tapis on les
bat on leur parle mal etc et quand elles
font le reproche la forme moi peu
importe et vont évidemment j'aurais
préféré que vous ne pensiez pas que vous
soyez pas machin a pricé lors elles sont
jeunes elles ont 20 ans le principal
c'est quoi c'est que en sorte ans
mademoiselle fait une vidéo youtube qui
va drainer 300000 vie où je sais bien
mais au vu un million de vues scène pour
des jeunes filles qui vont être qu'ils
vont peut-être la suivre et qui vont
avoir des informations et des liens
d'associations ou dead et l'idée c'est
que justement tout ces influenceurs dont
on n'arrête pas de dire qu'ils sont
inconsistants et qu'ils ne savent rien
faire ben pour une fois leurs messages
sont pas des messages rémunérés ou autre
mais des messages pour aider vous avez
alors est ce que est ce que vous avez
franchement j'ai kiffé parce que déjà ça
me donne envie elle mais en fait elles
m'ont donné envie donc cette fois sarah
el aillerie que ce soit elisabeth moreno
que ce soit marlène schiappa elles m'ont
donné envie est vraiment aujourd'hui
c'est une remise en question que j'ai
fait sur moi même et sur mon métro du
sein pour mieux le gouvernement
maintenant oui je connais un peu mieux
gouvernement et les stryges peut-être
laisse pas servir à quelque chose
ministre oui je sais castex bien sûr oui
liste de l'éducation dé l'éducation quoi
lui m'ont aidée en fait on est si elle
réalise le pas sur ces réseaux sociaux
si on n'est pas des faits des personnes
un peu feelgood personnes nous regardent
règle est donc bien sûr qu'elle est
obligée de rigoler et qu'on objets très
là c'est toi qui aimais présente magali
messieurs c'est comme ça que les gens
nous regardent et quelque part on est là
pour apporter de la bonne humeur donc on
a essayé de mélanger de mélange et de la
bonne humeur contre les gens nous
regardent et en même temps de diffuser
des messages et de mettre en lumière des
causes dont on va voir on va voir ce
qu'on pensait téléspectateurs oui ah bah
voilà ils leur place non à 85 ans qu'un
massacre ses nageoires 4 est ce que vous
les journalistes vous avez des gens
c'est parce que oui qu'est né le toit je
sais que le fond est bon mais la
télévision et tu le sais la télévision
c'est un média de forme car même en fle
son patient mais moi si c'était
peut-être pas fait pas les codes
venir à l'aller parisien construire je
fais si je peux évoluer je fais si je
peux apporter quelque chose je le ferai
que ça plaise ou pas et bien moi
j'avance c'est tout messianisme égalise
non c'est très productif mathieu parce
qu'on peut aider des gens et on peut
aider des associations et on peut aider
des coûts au niveau livre quand tu vois
le sondage à 86 % de gens qui disent il
avait rien maintenant franchement je
suis vraiment content parce que de toute
façon c'est à l'image de ce qu'on a pu
voir moi tout ce que je ferai la banque
a dit tout ce que je pourrais demander à
magali je pense que c'est ce travail là
il faudrait commencer par là essayez
déjà donné une autre image à nos jeunes
à nos enfants puisque on était quand on
voit la télé réalité aujourd'hui
sincèrement c'est une catastrophe c'est
quoi mais c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
question d'accord je fais des erreurs
j'ai les esprits bodjona mais non c'est
quoi vous voit comment être en vous
expliquer business magali magail et
comme vous êtes riche et comment vous
expliquez le sondage à 91 % des gens qui
disent que vous n'avez rien à [ __ ] là
bas mais parce que je m'en fous mais
comment vous l'expliquer parce que les
chambres des codes ici c'est des codes
twilight fait dans des cas hâter une
femme tu fermes tu te tais tu as des
faux seins t'es bête tu fais latéralité
bouille et ça pour moi j'en vois qu a
choisi
de dire que non moi qui suis une femme
j'ai 40 ans chine maman je m'assume je
travaillais la téléralité la témérité
m'a sauvé la vie et si moi je peux aider
je peux sauver la vie à des gens je le
ferai mais je ne voulais pas me
permettre je le connais vous magané si
je peux me permettre la jeune fille qui
à côté de loups qui était magnifique et
qu'il l'est toujours et toujours
magnifique naturellement avant de
démarrer la télé réalité et je pense que
ça cause de ce syndrome de la télé
réalité
vous trouve
très belle je n'ai pas bien des jeunes
filles qui sont parfaits tenter alors
si vous subissez pas gagner sur radio j
entends magali et je trouve que c'est
très touchant ton message
philanthropiques comme ça on a
l'ambition tout d'un coup ça et on
trouve été touché par la grâce se faire
détrôner de la générosité mais avant
tout avoue que c'est du business mais
calme les objets à gagner dans ce jean
thissen message qui vient d'être prêté
votre estimation mais cherating quoi
cette fois - étaient négatifs mais oui
nous avait négligemment pourquoi mais
vincent bessat chiens des troupes
c'était si terrible j'ai gagné deux
avocats 0 là bas - 28 ans coca zéro
alors oui on a enlevé nos masques parce
qu'on nous a donné à boire et annonce
que veut dire ce que cela donne une
bonne image moi g et besoin de vous
redonner une bonne image on attend de
codévelopper mais cela va y avoir des
questions mais gérable a voulu peut pas
me reprocher de me remettre en question
il évolua dans ma maladie cardiaque est
dit qu ya des enquêtes dans l'année des
réalités mais les lyonnais mais ménagé
samedi que seront les irradiés que
le racket mais c'est pas le sujet la
violence
et de signaler à pamela bach bien des
sujets très justement parce que l'image
n'était pas bonne au ministre voulez
vous voir dans cette une du marais
marché
j'aime ma fille je lui dirai je le dis
quand même elisabeth moreno certainement
tant pis ciel mais elle me dispute elle
annoncera des choses parce qu'on
travaille et on a avancé et on a pris
les décisions elle a pris des décisions
et on avance ensemble c'est donc a eu
beaucoup de mal dans la main et back
tant mieux sauf que mal à distinguer
lire magali soit on est sur quelque
chose quand on passe un message c'est
comme quand on fait une blague quand on
passe un message si le message arrive
mal fo a tonné de ses co la malle fait
passer au départ et je pense que
l'erreur il est juste là il est jusqu'à
lors des 90 ans quand les gens n'ont pas
les réveiller vous il ya 80% de la
jeunesse
intéressante et magali magail
mais regardez on a regardé
tout je ne vais pas le cacher
aujourd'hui dans mon âge on va arrêter
de dire des conneries on l'aurait alors
je préfère les mecs personnes addition
de certaines code vous allez pas me
reprocher c'est quand même les pages web
hier ils sont pas voter non payés c'est
de regarder si on peut ouvrir un peu les
mentalités peut voir